hello can't believe it's June already
[Applause]
alright Isabel what a romantic oh I
forgot I was a bear oh yeah
last time I played I got a house
extension a week sign thing I forgot
about that
I paid off my bill last time I played so
my house is gonna be a bit bigger now
okay Harvey Harvey wants a favor I've
only ever been around here's once so if
anyone doesn't know Animal Crossing
Harvey's is like a place where you go
and basically like take loads of photos
sorry this camera angle is annoying me
so I'm trying to make it straight but
it's not really working
[Music]
I have amiibos as well I haven't used
them maybe I should try anything yeah I
have hands okay so this cool you have
something to do today
gotta go help Harvey out okay Harvey on
come see you okay literally nothing has
changed since my birthday baby you
weren't here for my birthday then you
get to see it and we're probably gonna
have to clean it up a little bit
oh that looks like a big fish I missed
the colors of this game I should play
this one why haven't been playing this
oh yeah cause I've been playing The
Witcher which is also very good game
okay yeah it's boring it's nothing new I
wanted to put it anyway because
apparently there's loads of like new
bugs and fish that play
I look so cute as a bear I think I
prefer my animal crossing stuff than my
real self Wow oh my god I know so much
my god
and I got something from Amy
Amy's in the chat I got loads of stuff
right okay I bought some a telescope I
bought cake a jongara congratulations to
celebrate your new addition to your home
please accept this gift is and furniture
we hope this will inspire you to new
heights of design okay thanks
so you get to check out my big my big
house here's a good trick
try displaying a furniture that's all
the same color no that's the boy one
order do that we've completed the
expansion of your lovely home however
during construction we've made we had to
place one or more wall hanging items in
your storage yeah that's fine Oh is Deva
the unstoppable muffin another roommate
awesome so you're gonna what you're
gonna do with it
home theater art studio oh I know it's
gonna be my um it's gonna be my ah the
room that I want from me in real life
it's gonna be my work room people have
dreams I dream of a work room it's gonna
be a work room full of plants it's gonna
be like like working in the wilderness
and one of my other goals in life is to
have like a massive workroom and have
like a PC setup with all my like ready
to stream so I can just jump on it and
stream whenever I want to and also it'll
always have a camera set up as well and
enough room so that whenever I want to I
can finally start a stop-motion project
because I would love that just like some
things stop-motion to do every day my
mom sent me something fireflies light up
the night sky take your mind off the
stresses of the day as I watched amazed
and distract
the mosquitoes make that move that she
sounds like my real mom she goes bit all
the time
you're some wonderful new seasonal
offerings oh man I've been missing out
guys for you my love
oh thanks Amy what did you get me no I
don't know I've got so many presents I
don't know why Amy's in the chat so is
she forgot she wasn't sent to me ages
ago okay so I got myself a telescope and
I got myself some new music was it Amy
get me I don't know which ones from Amy
no a writing-desk that's cute they can
go money back room I love song did Amy
Amy did you give me a love song mums
handmade apron and that's cute probably
gonna sell that book stands perfect look
at my house what see down here then I
like taking a cruising it's chill
[Music]
[Music]
where's the love song I like this one
too is cute Wesley nice compressor there
it is it's about my head I think you
should sing this in wild world because I
know it somehow
[Music]
yeah maybe singing in wild love that was
the one I used to have well sounds so
different it's not how it used to sound
my boobs changed a little bit I guess I
need to get my jungle stuff out of my
storage because I know I know what
wallpaper I want in my new room
take a grunge is that okay key guys did
you see that were you oh I want this I
want to take there I want to put it in
my new room Elvis got me this old geezer
g-33 uses see I've got a little
workbench here you don't really need it
my bedroom now I can put something else
here
[Applause]
[Music]
okay let's have a look guys Wow Wow okay
what should we do with that let's look
at storage please get some sort of music
player in here because I'm not having a
quiet room okay we can take this that
make sense to have in our jungle room
plasma ball always fun even those I have
a radio but I also have this I have this
one very ukulele oh I can do love
experiments in this room is where it can
be cooking up some damn good and then
want to do these stupid paintings
wait jungle wall that's the one I can't
see what it says my face is in the way
white chocolates
no don't my chocolate actually I do want
chocolate they're not chopped up
flooring maybe I'll just have this one
for now
[Music]
oh yeah gotta find a new home for my
clownfish what how cool is this being in
a jungle I don't really like this
whatever I'll just keep it for now I
don't know there's a writing desk whoa
it's
[Music]
I'll just quickly place this stuff in
for now I can be crazy with it later on
iced tea this'll be easier I like these
because they like they light up look if
I do this
turn it on some other time look stance
needs oh sorry hey Jesus this is gonna
be a real messy room I am I think that
it's pretty here for now socket as you
know okay all the corners
oK we've got the start of something
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
first life
okay
hey Lenny
hey sky catus celesta island oh I don't
know what you mean by that
[Music]
I'm guessing you guys cannot hear me cuz
no one said anything you know I might
just sell this clown fish as out of cell
stuff Oh someone saw something okay see
how many Oh
so please look really pretty what that's
before I've never never get my that well
they look so pretty what the hell
well maybe they're just changing with
the seasons pretty wheeze I'm gonna keep
them
ah the God hasn't had a good sacrifice
for quite a while I don't have anything
good to give it sorry God
okay he's quite forgiving
Oh golden trees
[Music]
honey make well do you want him I don't
want anymore
can give him away
[Music]
okay I'm gonna try and clean up some of
this spray every day yeah
[Music]
wait oh my gosh no I need the fresh
things fresh the reason why I wanted to
play this just because I want to make
sure that bill hasn't gone because bill
is my favorite hello camel I'll come
back
Ami's online see look everything is
exactly the same as when I left it I
need to figure out guys see you tell me
in the chat what do you think I should
do with this area like should I keep all
the decking and maybe turn it into like
a stage or like a communal space or like
a dining area and nap place like what
can it be
do you think such a supply this is a
mosquito that's nude I don't know
where's gosh
still there
it is hot what
got it yes I haven't had a mosquito yet
it stage what for like music and stuff
because I was gonna put a stage on the
other side of my island
but maybe I'm thinking maybe I'll make
that make a yoga retreat
I want more like spooky
but a stiva this is built off
[Music]
okay he's still here as long as he's not
thinking about leaving then all is well
in my Animal Crossing island I need to
finish off this pathway now cuz I got my
bridge done
oh wait a diva yeah I know I need to go
in my face oh yeah it could be like an
event space maybe I'm sorry but your
Islanders to oranjee my island is corner
on her Island actually sir makes sense
nose working and playing The Witcher
[Music]
oh I want this person to leave can you
just leave my Ireland please please Amy
didn't want him and then he came round
over to my Island I'm like I know what
you look adorable that's what I'm for
the I'm a that's a good one tonight
[Music]
thanks for watering
[Music]
[Music]
doot-doot doot-doot down how you
tweeting oh yeah I've got this thing
that I need someone to blame
oh my god I forgot like the simple joys
of this game Bill's wearing my jumper
I've gotta take a picture of this and
send it to everybody all my friends all
the way over there can someone take a
screenshot of wait wait let me oh wait
no I can take a picture wait okay bail
wait let me put my shovel right don't
move
hey no no no no no huh wait stay the
Westies take take take take take take
take
okay wait stay stay
No ah but stay stay stay stay stay stay
stay stay stay
oh my god stop leave me
bill look at the camera
oh wait can I do this somehow I do that
still this is like my whole entire time
of playing this game cuz I just love
taking pictures of belt belt
oh it's present in this guy I have to
get this picture
we're not progressing until I get this
picture okay still there
[Music]
okay this might be the perfect dose
producers go to act quit guys no bill
bill bill I can't see you jumper a hedge
is on the way Oh bill bill let me push
you over here I want you to be over here
come over here they'll stop moving
turn around everyone wants to see a
beautiful jumper turn around oh yeah
yeah nearly nearly nearly uh kinda no no
no bill bill bill
yeah yeah yeah yeah that way yah yah yah
yah yah yah yah yah yah yah yah yah wait
let me smile or something let me do
something
yeah no fashions oh this is worth it
so worth it fine I don't care anyway you
know I care about you both Oh Oh bill
you're so cute cat Fievel whoo my heart
fluttered like that's how she speak to
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I think there's a schoolgirl outfit I
got your bag oh hell yeah I got a ninja
costume you see what
let me turn yes my color as well thank
you oh that's actually quite a cute
little apron I like my bear costume
right
moving my head out of the way a little
bit more so I could see more of the game
what should we do should we go
[Music]
that was new kind of battlements game
it's so long this is my playground if
you guys why have I got so many negative
emotions
[Music]
we're gonna get rid of one of these cut
it with hop right cuz that's already
cheerful
no that's good joy that's always a nice
one right
oh hello you don't belong that but I
need to eat some fruit see I haven't
even finished doing this part
thanks for subscribing silicon solo
cornered II don't worry xk programmer
you can definitely get a mask it'll just
come separate with the ninja costume and
now put this where it belongs
here we go
[Music]
I need to duck out but I libel just go
work on it bit by bit
oh this is another present
did I pick up that present from earlier
so online I'm running out of room
already you just sell some stuff
oops
[Music]
whoo yeah why not I'm basically cool
because I got all my money into my house
the last time I played this is where you
belong with your other friends
[Music]
in the secret garden
hate that the hedges don't actually grow
properly until that place with the area
surrounding them so I'm gonna have to
throw them for us then Bree place them
back there yes how was not aware when I
first did it
more weeds I love these squeeze enough
of these changed
I'm glad the reason I think there are a
lot prettier now you know what I don't
think they've changed have they changed
I don't know Amy have they changed okay
I'm full now so I need to go and sell
some stuff
[Music]
I'm probably not gonna play the last
misty when it comes out I don't know why
I think just cause like I'm playing the
which I've always play it a little bit
later I'll go you're watching the PS 5
showcase apologies for dis yawning
everyone why also I don't understand
this new sticker business I feel like
I'm really out of the loop how many
hours I have in this game I'm really not
that many in comparison to most people
do players like I say I haven't played
it in like almost a month now so I can
give the mosquito at least something new
scared of bugs
[Music]
nope
[Music]
ah Amy says that the weeds have changed
good I'm not just going crazy there I
thought they'd change
okay I'm gonna solve some stuff and then
I will carry on looking for fossils
hey I'm Jean Nico I need this for my
bedroom right now and the hot days it
gets way too hot who's telling
crossbones is an Amana sell stuff a
bunch of SAP sorry guys I don't want to
sell my bad dude
now keep did you do you do oh yeah I
need to put the sound someone cares
everything I mean all stones that sticks
I'll just sell this
I want this how do I get it you know
NEMA they might just be releasing him
back to the wild or giving into a nice
[Music]
[Music]
I like these long ones playing whoa look
it's just going crazy up that
[Music]
okay you again coming in to clean up
I remember when I played Animal Crossing
wild wild this is like all I did and you
can even sell them so obsessive that you
cut the part isn't it Park
[Music]
oh hey guys I did say that we would go
visit Amy
so I need to find the rest of these
fossils check out the PO shop I'll do
I'll do the photography thing another
day
[Music]
we got one of those
[Music]
[Music]
whoa
I mean it does make sense for these to
be around two counts light but maybe not
this many if it was in this release
like this
[Music]
take you up ever taking a look about my
well yeah I can't remember
bloody well
[Music]
this is the coolest radio the little uh
evil skull
weirdest tongue as well
anyway
you know fossils around here Oh
Wow
[Music]
I mean this makes us to be like this why
won't you
[Music]
[Music]
and these these wants to grow right now
so I'm going to grow on the edge all
right let's see what happens put you
here experiment because uh yeah they
don't like grow their buds or like
whatever the holiday if they don't have
enough space around them I think it's at
least one square all the way around
Oh whole koala friend oh you with them
[Applause]
okay
[Music]
let's go into the shop oh they're not in
season yeah that makes them okay well
I'm just moving stuff around for no
reason I know trees can't grow if
they're too close they have gotten all
the passing designs that I can out
I'm good thanks can as I got apples it
was a chef outfit I thought it was like
a schoolgirl outfit
I would want to first saw like all of
her little poses I was in fits of
laughter I thought it was absolutely
hilarious get a tiger dress it's weird
forget it it's kind of cool what color I
mean that's got orange in it but I kind
of like there this one too oh it's like
me in real life oh this one brings up my
hair this one brings out my eyes
it's bringing bring about my hair this
one brings out my eyes this one brings
out my head this one brings out my eyes
I think I'm gonna get for this one
hmm
how long was room for not very long
today I haven't had dinner yet so
probably till about half
sevenish half seven eight ish a nose
drip
you know that's disgusting I love it
[Music]
like I think I've got these ones
why don't they do orange shoes am I sure
I don't want this one I mean I could is
my breath but it does look cool so could
just wear long she's like with not
jumping out of my nose just wear a lot
of black could wear my black tights -
nah yeah I'm gonna get this one I got a
lot black hate Florida oh that's cute
I'm glad you called this live stream I
try and do every Thursday although I
might change the day because I've been
invited to quiz nights on Thursdays now
so well say yeah that koalas he's a
stupid super cool koala I think I think
this will do guys what do you think I
think I look pretty snazzy
now this one
I want to have my hair down for this
though sucks I have to go all the way
home to do that what is this oh it's pig
bears all right buddy
[Music]
[Music]
ah so for those of you who have just
joined we are raising money for black
lives matter while doing this stream so
I'll just get the page up we'll see see
if there's any changes right now where
we've done really well
we're on 219 pounds but thank you so
much to everyone
oh look at that it's 7:05 thank you so
much to everyone who donated on Sunday I
have made sure to put your donations in
our yakima whoa Yaga muffin damn
Yaga muffin my gosh yeah come over and
just put in a hundred dollars thank you
so much that's really generous really
appreciate that Jesus and it's going for
a very important very important cause so
thank you thank you so much Oh what just
happened
everything just went down
okay well I guess we'll go back to the
life yeah thank you so much so you just
fit you put a little heart they're super
cute so that means cuz the goal is four
hundred pounds yeah seventy four seventy
four percent of the way there already
guys pretty damn good
pretty damn good okay
[Music]
oh I need to find out one of the bottles
there will be a bottle oh my god I love
this ball look guys
I could just do this for ages
wow this game is so good
oh hello ah bill you see why he's my
favorite
oh sure I mean I'm not I'm not pre
conceiving what is it oh hell yeah
thank you I think I've already got one
of these that's okay I can sell that
make some money
oh yeah I think I need to go home anyway
because I think I've got some tickets
mr. Harrer anyway yeah give me a large
yeah I get a large rug than a medium rug
yeah and then get a mystery then I'm go
back up my other tickets and get the
other mystery basically you get tickets
per rug size and when you get up to five
tickets you get a free mystery flooring
or wallpaper this is one of the quality
of life things that animal costume
really needs to get better you need to
be able to choose multiple things
[Music]
instead of just having to reboot
conversations with people over and over
this is my idea
[Music]
I shall do at least he knows then give
me the flooring well I'm gonna get me
the tickets tempt you okay let's go home
oh look at you being so helpful wait
weren't the chairs here just now what
that hell happened to the chance to have
any events coming up
my birthday
Lucy hides a job I got a bill cos Bill's
his name oh yeah I owe you now in
dancing forever
is that just like the like the roof
basically the roof color
can sell all of this did you do do do do
do
[Music]
you know I'm really sad though because
I've already had that uh-oh what am I
talking about
yeah no no I don't want no um my
favorite are Linda from wild world wild
world isn't in New Horizons and that
makes me really sad so I mean I got bill
but he's not Russia he she they there no
Russia
what was it oye we want to change oh
also I should probably take that thing
off my door I'll do it when I get back
out
[Music]
okay Danny and Judah
I won no I need more hairstyles as well
come on Nintendo give me more hairstyles
everyone has this hairstyle but it's
like the best the best one the best like
long haired one and we need more oh I
didn't set it I just like every time I
get changed
weirdo
where is it so change it color No
[Music]
beautiful
Oh No ah
[Music]
Callay I love this right so I only
noticed like a couple of streams ago
that clay clay Heil will just pop into
the stream and just say clay and like
nothing else and then everyone went
crazy was like play and eyes look down
like clay what and then I got told
afterwards that apparently for quite a
few streams every now and then you'll
just pop in if you're still here you'll
just pop into the stream and you'll just
say clay and nothing else and I think
that's hilarious it's like we've got our
own kind of like Groot symbol and but
instead of being like oh my god this
firefight instead of being like I am
Groot you just like clay I love that
it's like a little mystery to the
channel and nygma clearly yeah
alright thankfully you can't you can't
say nay I know they don't take papers
very annoying okay so what do I need to
do now right I need you to look at my my
fossils
and take this Firefly are we supposed to
put up skull and crossbones on my door
darn it I didn't do that and then if we
have time I was thinking we could go and
visit Amy
if Amy's still up for it okay that's
fine but I do have something out
bioluminescence
it's caused by a chemical reaction in
the rump females while their larvae
larvae
larvae turn on the ground to put off
predators we dine on snails
I love it when they sing
I heard you don't act all shy soon you
know look at my little bird friends
getting alone
[Music]
it's so
[Music]
see you singing come on carry on
Duncan shy Ron I wish other people that
you sing
[Music]
that's already sad song why are you
singing that song why are you singing
the sad song that's fun from my haunted
island that's the song from my haunted
woods that's the song the Haunted Woods
plays
are you okay have you been possessed by
a spirit from the haunted well
[Music]
I'm gonna take video of this for proof
keep singing
zing please I'm running on 30 seconds of
fridge when we mommy mom so spooky or
the hell I can't remember Hot Fuzz
either it's been so long
okay that sells some stuff oh yeah I'm
always gonna do my house it's gonna get
all the rest of the tickets right okay
one sec sell some stuff
I should put that in my storage it will
have botanical rug
Oh that'll go with what I'm trying to do
here forgot one thing wait
dude
sorry this is a very like sneaky gay
[Music]
right let's not forget to do the things
paddle right like not I don't want to
open the door I want to pick up my okay
that's porphyrin don't want that Amy do
you want the pawprint doorframe if I'm
gonna come up with you a bit let me know
[Music]
our cross button ticket oh darn it I
still don't have enough cuz you need
five so I still don't have enough money
so I'll just put them back in the yeah
if you want say okay I'll give you my
paw print one put this in storage type
that and storage so I can find a place
which guy
give that to Amy that in storage that
storage check these guys out later
[Music]
[Music]
my lighthouse is looking good oh I
certainly found that message in a bottle
yet usually they come every day what
were they doing now
oh yeah I've gotta get small one so hard
just as that every size is that favor
size my heart and purse okay and then I
just want your
okay and now I'll go to Amy's I'll
probably just oh it's fine I probably
just gonna aim these guys and then I'll
probably leave about eight but before I
do that just a little reminder that
we're trying to raise what we are
raising we're not trying when we are
trying but we're succeeding in raising
money for black lives matter that's you
guys again this is bug webs matter that
is to share to your friends
the I'll put the link actually zoom labs
should be sending out the link as well
but I'll send the link out to you in a
bit
and right now we're at 74% of the goal
which is wide say one oh my god I just
refresh the room we're already over
thank you so much Amy and thank you so
much Colin Wow cuz I did call it if that
was a if this is Colin Williams I did
put in your donation from Sunday as well
but unfortunately super chat takes 30
percent from anything that you give but
I did put that in from you
with them damn I know
leave me alone oh this is amazing thank
you so much guys I mean if you still
wanted to make more than welcome to
I might doing something but I'm not
gonna what I might a will but I'm not
gonna do it now cuz I never realize how
to put my card details and I'm not
letting you guys see that but I'm so
frickin charged thanks guys
that's great oh good ah let's get back
don't be shy you guys are never shy
never shy ah that's made me really happy
I did not expect to see that when i
refresh the page thank you very much
everyone was donated by drained or Yaga
muffin ami
Colin me you're all crate and we hadn't
them anonymous donors well I don't know
who that was but thank you to whoever it
was just in case you're here right now I
want a flat I can't believe it I did she
I didn't think we'd ever go I don't even
reach for holy it alone surpass it
that's amazing
no I don't use my little mouse ticket I
want to go and visit a friend
[Music]
I was gonna put on some black tights and
Wow way too much of a perfectionist I
mean the kind of red orange socks go
with my just a hat and my hats all gasp
you know I haven't seen Amy in six
months so one look good for yes all
right Amy I'm coming oh thank you so
much Colleen I really appreciate that
cause like I'm sorry I didn't realize I
should have known and she'd of like told
you guys but thank you anyway because
that's so amazing
did I do it so I can't believe it
[Music]
Wow you got a lot of flowers I've got a
flower on my team Plessy whoa look at
that jeez you put so much time into your
Island since I last came here damn girl
I come here to bite my sloth on all of
your things
hello
I love your headpiece with you
ah hell yeah you don't like um was it
you know like have you seen midsummer
that horror film and like at the end
they like crown someone like flower
Queen or something but basically they
just kill a bunch of people it's like a
big like clan I don't know hi this is
cute I don't know you can make your
signs colorful if you wait let me send
you let me give you my thing before I'm
before I forget they again
that's the pole print oh yes
I don't know how to like
all right Amy give me the tour I'm
following
oh cool what the hell is this
so wolf with kids
are those human baby suckling from its
teat whoa this is Sookie I love this
little shell no picnic fit the shell
entrance I need to get more happy happy
things let me get happy things I've got
so many sad ones oh I'll get the clap
that work well I do have this thing is
wrong
[Music]
okay where to next
[Music]
houses Barbara's house
but is this just like oh wait no I I
just probably follow you Amy I'm coming
oh wow
ah so campsite ah hell yeah that's cool
wait I think I saw this before you've
changed where it is yeah used to be like
at the top of the island or something
wait well I want to play this one how do
I get to that one I don't play the other
one want to play that thing that's on
the floor I can't play it I can't get to
it
[Music]
hey you got Sahara - you got these
turtles everywhere Turtle Island whoa
what's in here
you can keep outfits in there you've got
a chicken outfit no you keep outfits I
thought that was for beer Oh what the
hell is this it's an octopus whoa
[Music]
whoa oh my god the teddy bears are
having that picnic wow that's super cool
wait can I can I can I thank you
that's so cool oh my god I love this
[Music]
the Leaning Tower of Pisa little love
bench okay I'm coming up now dad I
thought that gnome was wearing shades
for a second or like there's one cool no
is this your house is it your house no
dos o clap or something if yes
[Music]
yes please yes yes I would have spoken
is it your house I'm guessing it's your
house
it looks bigger than the other ones yeah
you got wha have you got an upstairs and
stuff this is crazy Amy you've been
paying so much I've totally been
neglecting our thing
[Music]
[Music]
hey Bob ruff arcade hell yeah that's so
cool oh I wish we could play them like I
wish they're really little mini games
this flooring is super freakin cool wow
so cool
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
Oh
it's a cute little kitchen oh my god
does it sing - please send me a sings oh
it doesn't sing I wanted to do it -
saying can you get changed from your
fridge as well this is so wet what's in
here mmm yes
Pierce pricked my finger on this I will
sleep for all eternity sorry I will
close this for you now they go
hmm scanners you want to live on Amy's
Island what she just randomly went this
is cool wow it's like so steamy and
stuff this is so cool
did I catch her pre pin caught your
pooping didn't I
you got a tourist bathtub I've got this
one as well super cool let me go pee
can i yeah let me on I want to sit on it
why kind of sit on it can I'm not sit on
it what I can't sit on it okay I give up
I can sit on this one that okay
how many floors have you got let's go
down to the basement oh I do love the
interactive wallpapers and stuff in this
game it's so cool this is like a dark
dusty den I love it
[Music]
that's really fun table football hell
yeah it's like a man cave I love it I
could do some work
wait if I could get on the chair bridge
I can but that's fine keep sneaking
through her stuff and it's just keeps
telling me that she has the same outfit
oh don't go around there why should why
is it music nan I guess you just want it
to be very dormant okay I see wedding
event was there a wedding event how much
have I missed what the hell
[Music]
[Music]
this is what I want my bedroom wall to
be like at home this is like crazy
I want this from my real home but I
don't think my estate agents would be
too happy whoa this is weird music it
was cut straight to bed stripped asleep
cartoons hell yeah
[Music]
is this like Tom and Jerry
[Music]
the closest thing to socializing we've
had in so long well I mean like me and
Amy look like snotty nose so gross they
should have made the snot like yellow
disgusting oh that's a cute idea putting
the telescope so you can see it out of
the window
your rooms quite girly and bluest I
guess this was the wedding thing what
wedding do I miss her I miss a wedding
oh the wedding event is the thing okay
okay no one tell me about the wedding
thing I will go to Harvey's house
eventually I'll find out what this
wedding event is yeah let's see the rest
of the of Amy's wait I'm stuck oh let's
see the rest of a wheeze Island and then
I'm gonna go make dinner and don't
forget PS five showcase tonight I'm so
excited it's 9 p.m. where I am in
England PST time I'm not sure everywhere
else but it's so soon I'm so excited
where to now
[Music]
is she taking me oh cool
I like this Sookie is creepy
I can hear some music coming from up
here where to now where the music was
coming from
smile it means it was going somewhere
oh sorry just become this way I'm in it
[Music]
in Bob's his head
how many cool things
sorry I'm playing with stuff another
giant bear oh yeah I've got this one in
my bedroom it's the same one as mine
[Music]
I like how you've done of sectioned off
parts of your islands with color scheme
color flowers the mystic mystical part
what's here I like the fireflies I'm
rubbing a firefighter it's cute ooh
beehives
yeah just just testin Justin gay would
be funny if it's a wasp came down oh my
god I just realized this is where the
music's coming from wait what is a me
okay um yeah yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
ah Thank You Mackin I can't see your
name I'm sorry but thank you for saying
nice things about confection really
appreciate that still baffles me that
people still play oh my god daddy that's
what my friend teddy bear with cope and
I was a kid well he was actually good
Ted but you know similar he's so cute
and I want him in my island
cute little aha pathway I just got one
of these to be nice another turtle you
know I should have like spot the turtles
and if you find them or you get a prize
or something snapping turtles where to
now
oh we could play chess
my go my go I go I go I go oh my god oh
my God my God my God my God my God my
God
this is dick
I just don't want to lose I'm a sore
loser and I wanna lose the game
what's for dinner kind of says good
question I actually don't I don't know I
might just Chuck stuff into a pot and
make a big grassy soupy thing just cuz
it's easy and it's quick
wait where're we going this way oh I
wish something happened with this big
pyramid always like what the tops come
off because I think the top oh no it
disappears when I do that the top looks
like it's texture is slightly different
so it looks like it should be able to do
something but it's but it never does
another one
this is cute
[Music]
[Music]
look at this oh yeah I was gonna do that
can I do it from behind now oh nice one
I like your see these sculptures I think
the butterfly ones are the best ones
they're so nice this one looks really
cool oh this one's called soon ah that
must be a fossil
ah that's cute Wow was this given
Mabel's place like a lot more to do it's
nice cool
I had a winter one of those I think I
sold it it's very nice
[Music]
yeah like you know whenever you visit
people's islands you just feel like that
islands are like so much bigger than
yours like I have no idea why I'm right
now in this island oh wait oh my god do
you have a playground as well oh that's
so cure you've got hopscotch and you've
got your own balls well wait can you not
cannot do this anything with this one
what yep
I know you can't get
[Music]
whoa oh my gosh uh no they are bamboo
blonde I don't got that one you sure I
don't know which one's up I don't know
oh my god there's so many that I don't
have but you can make a giant teddy bear
I'm taking this one ah thanks I don't
know what this is
wand but that one gone
racoon figurine hell yeah excited I
[Music]
think I just have on my old outfit yeah
I like how we both just randomly named
girls Kelly just with different
spellings skinny twins yeah exactly
twins
oh my god why are we so alike what the
hell well I've been speaking right now
and there's like this'll a flower house
Wow
oh my god it actually is there's so many
flowers here wait I have a flower I'm
gonna put it down your flower huh I have
two flowers but I have this one two
there you go
I just gave you more flowers
she's like no no no no no no
Wow
oh and now we're back to the top we made
it all the way this amazing island how
many stars we got now Amy tell me in the
chat if you hear this summon how many
stars you've got because I am very
intrigued way I think I've got that I'm
very inch and bicurious and how many
stars do you have
[Music]
I'm not mean I gave her flowers she
obviously one says the flowers of course
amy has five sighs well congratulations
all very very proud of you
Oh scheisse whether they just do
everyone congratulate me on her
five-star accomplishments it takes a
long time to get five stars he is an
accomplishment
there any other flowers well actually
can I can I take flowers because I will
from your flower help not from anywhere
else in your Islands just the flower
help
okay
cool I will take your flowers which
one's all I have I don't have this one
okay now I do feel bad if I give you
this flower I don't have the purple one
Oh for [ __ ] sake I was just trying to
know what's trying to do this and let's
hit the buds off I'm sorry
wait other ones that I don't think I
have this one right and now I'll do it
like this
I think that might be about it one
supposes oh I don't know if I have these
velocity
yeah I think that's about it this place
you haven't managed to get yourself like
a golden flower I mean I don't know how
you make those I've just seen people
have them
okay that's it a gum I guess the flowers
where's maiya thank you where's my bow
its apologetic Wow I'll be with you soon
I need to find about I know I have a bow
the hell
well what would it be cause opponent is
it apologetic oh I thought that was like
a thank you
well that's definitely no way to say
thank you sorry
I think this up by accident I didn't
mean to
okay well thank you so much Amy for
sharing me your Island I am probably
gonna leave now so do you want to escort
me back to the others a cute light
alright thanks for having me
oh yeah I forget that I don't have I
don't wear shoes when I'm in this outfit
bye Amy
thank you for showing us your five-star
Ireland it was very cute you did a great
job I'm very very proud of you very
proud of you this game is so wholesome
okay I'm gonna go gonna go now oh wait
now I have to do this and I'm gonna go
now
but before I do let's have a look at the
the fundraising page because we are
raising money like last matter because
it's very important and everyone needs
to realize this and I think it's good
because people are which is great
needed so let's check out the charity
page I'll also I'll give you the link to
actually now as I'm showing you
[Music]
my items like nothing you can person
it's a little humble you know I could
spend a little bit more time on it but
it's exciting to see other islands
because it gives you ideas of what you
might want to do in your life like Amy's
kind of she's like figured out little
nooks and crannies I don't even know
what you could do with your Island now I
mean you've made it looks so cool places
clay I think that's clays way of saying
that they like your Island
[Music]
okay so let's go back to the fundraising
page just have a little look I'm gonna
just refresh it
425 pounds that's so crazy I actually I
actually can't believe we've managed to
raise that much and I still haven't put
in my money yet I put in a little bit
but I want to put in more damn Thank You
mantas for adding five pounds to the
donation so cool we just surpassed our
Tiger already I am so happy thank you so
much if you aren't already please do
follow me on Twitter on Instagram you
can join us in the discord and I will
let you know the grand total once I put
my money into it
I'm just gonna give you guys LSL LSL
invites to the discord just in case you
want to join
wait oh yeah what I'm trying to use my
trackpad I have a mouse what is wrong
with me I've forgotten how to use
trackpads now
so yeah please do join the discord if
you want to
hey thanks da may also follow me on
twitter twitter twitter twitter twitter
to Twitter and Instagram
to find out what I do more daily and
also to figure out to find out how much
money we've made overall I mean either
way we've surpassed our target I'm so
happy thank you so much for everyone
that contributed and even if you didn't
contribute thank you so much just for
the spending this evening with me
helping keep me sane hopefully I can
help you keep saying as well I really
appreciate it everything that you do
honestly it's and thank you Amy for
letting us join you in your Island
thank you for being here tonight yes
this kids it's good dad I got you guys I
am um also if I can ask just one more
favor from you guys um I really probably
silly I know that I won't do it I want
doing I would don't why don't I don't
want doing um I'm an enigma
right okay I'm gonna just I'm gonna just
save my game yeah oh wait no diva sod
this is why you can just never stop
playing Animal Crossing why do you
decide you okay what's up yes
oh you don't have to be happy for me
it's okay like I don't care you can be
you I'm not gonna judge Oh bill you're
so cute wait wait wait this is the
perfect photo opportunity with bill oh
wait I'm dressed as a skeleton I don't
want this
okay bill just stay that do not mean no
yeah yeah gets order out even better
okay where's my wand all right what do I
want we dress that does which maybe I
will just revert my outfit we're now
I'ma gesture with it's not he knows oh
whatever
all right photo op I don't know he's got
this you to frame it well
oh yeah
[Music]
[Music]
Oh bill yeah
just walks away
by Bell okay I need to leave I need to
eat okay this is why my town just stays
the same because all I do is come in
here and take pictures be cool
wait what I left you hanging what do you
mean
he's done with the photo no never
I will forever take pictures with Belle
he's my favorite
oh yeah no I know it's find it
uh shut up my outfits is not ver in the
pic scanners shut up right I am actually
gonna go now so I'm gonna say good buddy
who I can see in the chat so bye Amy bye
scanners by Jamie by Mantha's by
gabriela pin MC by someone out of it by
mantas did I already see bikes scanners
by scanners by Colin Williams I thank
you so much again for your donation
really really appreciate it
[Music]
bye thanks Gamow and I will see you guys
next week and don't forget keep your
eyes peeled I'll let you know how much
room phrase to ever all thank you so
much for being here tonight and have a
lot with your evening
bye